What is a woman you like? Is that an
error?  Oh well,
I was going to do it in hiding,
it's beautiful, it's
not uncommon to have otaku hobbies in the field, there's no need to hide it,
but after all, the people in the riajuu area  You look at me with white eyes, and
when I tell Gunma Isesaki Bakura that I'm giving you a good morning kiss,
most of them pull back.
If you're a science-related freak, I'll
judge things with a silly emotional theory
There's no definition or rule that a love target must be a human
Human's sexual tastes are diverse and there's no sperm in them In the
first place, game characters are attractive  An ideal personality imagined by combining various elements
It's the same as a goose idol, so to speak, including the fact that it's almost impossible to actually become a lover.
It
's the same thing as having a high-quality sound
with ak
Beep and socializing.  ] I
'm sorry, Yukimura-senpai, look at the chest pain go down Then
it's the same as before, yeah